gone gone gone still here just a lot
bigger probably gone before 2012 mostly
gone but my house will be fine right
tons of rice top three things I'm gonna
hate about 2012 one of them is losing
probably all my Facebook friends
well DVDs and DVRs pretty much all
you're gonna have is I can be television
anymore I'm certainly not going to see
any new episodes of Dogtown no Dog
Whisperer I'm a dog whisperer actually
dogs you won't even be able to get a dog
I quit my job well I didn't technically
quit it and I gave him a two-year notice
but once two years is up sayonara 2012
what year is that for the super bowl
what super bowl is uh oh that's right
there won't be one this is about a Sleep
Number 24 my usual
is about 45 so clearly I have some
adjusting to make I can handle the 24
for you know at least a little bit
post-2012 you're not able to get sushi I
should come over this guy's house having
to re-watch Waterworld I think there's a
lot to learn from that movie and this is
the best spot people say when there's a
tornado or hurricane get in the bathtub
and put a mattress over you I say well
if there's a 2012 coming make the bed
become the bathtub